hey everyone this is feed a master
Costilla Kavinsky here for chess calm
and today I'm going to be going over a
new opening known as the Queens gambit
declined the Queens gambit declined
starts after d4 d5 c4 this is the
so-called Queens gambit so if black
takes the pawn here on c4 that would be
the Queens gambit accepted which we've
already covered here on YouTube so today
we're going to be looking at how black
should play if they want to decline the
gambit with a move like ecigs this
opening is known as one of the most
classic defenses that there is what I
mean by classic is based on very general
and proven opening principles things
like controlling the center developing
pieces quickly and efficiently and
castling as soon as possible so why
should also be developing their pieces
in the center and Bishop e7 now Bishop
g5 it's important for white to play
Bishop g5 before he plays III said he
doesn't block his Bishop in castles III
and now h6 this is an important move
because it's what we call putting a
question to the bishop now White has to
make a decision
he either gives this bishop up and takes
your knight he moves his Bishop back to
f4 which means that there's no longer
this pressure here on g5 or the bishop
goes back to h4 which means that the
bishop can never return on this diagonal
so after Bishop h4 I think black can
play b6 there's another move here 94
this is known as the Alaska defense of
the Queens gambit declined and basically
black in trade some pieces right away
something like Bishop e7 Queen e7 Rick
c1 c6 and this variation is
very solid for black he's going to play
97 b6 there should be seven at some
point you'll probably take this knight
on c3 he'll play rook C a rook d8 and
he'll play for the c5 break which as
you'll see later on is very common the
other option here for black which is I
think slightly more popular is b6 and I
think the reason this is more popular is
because you don't trade so many pieces
right away which usually makes the game
more interesting both lines are very
solid for black what that means is why
it's going to have to take a lot of risk
and when white creates risk that means
black gets winning chances to Lefter b6y
can play Bishop d3 there should be seven
castles and now black can take on c4
it's important that you don't take on c4
before white developed suspicions
because that would be wasting time after
white plays Bishop d3 he's already moved
his bishop once and then if you take on
c4 that means why does the move his
Bishop again to recapture the pawn and
the point of taking on c4 is now our
bishop has this great diagonal and black
and now play Knight B d7 and his idea is
to play c5 next and challenge white
centre-right then you can support this
with moves like rook c8 Queen c7 bring
the other Rick to da
so generally play in the center slowly
improve your pieces and take advantage
of any mistakes your opponent makes
meanwhile White's plan in this position
is to do something like Queen e2 bring
both of his rooks in the center and at
some point you can try to push efore and
e5 or d5 and white as you can see is
also going to be playing in the center
slowly getting space improving his
pieces he can try for things like ninety
five at some point followed by f4
possibly creating some kind of play on
the kingside that's pretty much all you
need to know if you want to play this
opening for either color let's just
quickly review d4 d5 controlling efore
c4 and a six the reason that the two
most popular moves in this position re6
and c6 is that if white takes on d5 you
can recapture with a pawn and continue
controlling efore let's say c4 e6 Knight
c3 negative six and remember this move
h6 putting the question to the bishop
and your main idea here is to develop
your Knight to d7 rook c8 and then c5 if
you can play c5 before bringing your
rook to c8 go ahead and do that the
sooner you can play it safely the better
right some point if you want you can
also take this pawn on c4 and open up
your Bishop on the long diagonal so I
hope you guys enjoy this quick lesson on
the Queens gambit declined I wish you
good luck in your future games thanks a
lot for listening and I'll see you
around on chess calm